hi good morning or good afternoon
depending where you are you have three
of us here from India Pakistan and
Bangladesh my name is Robert Bajaj I'm a
member of parliament
remember how sabha in India and chairman
of the Bajaj group including a companies
like Bajaj Auto which manufactures
motorcycles we are here in Davos
freezing temperatures from 5 degrees
below to 14 degrees below centigrade we
300 friends and especially mr. sorry
Hussain Dawood and I have known each
other for more years than I remember
baby he returned where he speaks maybe
15 years or even 20 years and we are all
from this part of the world it's a
continent India Pakistan Bangladesh we
were one country yes we countries will
remain three countries but the people of
these countries as far as I'm concerned
perhaps my two friends at Excel or one
we are brothers sisters that's what we
have been for centuries in 52 years
doesn't separate us and our strengths
will come from working together
independent people independent countries
but working together economically
politically there have been some
differences in the past for various
reasons this is not the occasion two
reasons for that
there is no question of who's right
who's wrong we would all like to work
together economically socially and
politically and once you start doing
that and I hope and my believe my
friends also hope that I think there is
no part of the world which can prevent
South Asia we don't want to become a
military part no but an economic power a
humane economic power you will have
growth with social justice we will have
what we call inclusive roads so this
tremendous poverty
it means poverty in all our three
countries would be substantially reduced
if not eliminated and we we are already
proved to be Indians at Pakistanis and
Bangladeshis but we will hold our head
still further high not much arrogance
but the pride and say we are Indians we
are Bangladeshis
we are Pakistanis and the world this
already started respecting us during the
last few years we'll stand up much
salute us we say hi how are you and we
have Sunnah days to come with people
from the west from the developed world
would like to come and work in India and
even settle down and retire in India or
well - all of you and my times to all of
you for listening to us thank you very
much you have heard my friend Rahul
Bajaj speak this is my turn
my name is Fazle Hassan Abu I have been
working in rural development in
Bangladesh for 38 years working in
education health rural development and
poverty alleviation and over the last
seven eight years I've been working in
Afghanistan Pakistan Sri Lanka Tanzania
Uganda Southern Sudan like lean Sierra
Leone because I think the way of getting
people out of poverty we have done some
good effective work in Bangladesh and
some of it could be replicated in other
countries not only in South Asia but
also we can contribute to Africa so I
think that whatever we know we want to
share with others and Africa not being
very fortunate in their leadership and
lacking in institutions we can help them
in provide in providing institutions so
that they can also come out of poverty
because there is there are lots of very
energetic people very entrepreneurial
people in Africa - and we are trying to
help them and my next job is going to be
working in Haiti to reforest Haiti to
start a bank which will provide
financial services to small and medium
enterprises so I hope that all of us
from South Asia will be proud to be able
to do something for less fortunate
people in Africa and in Haiti so I hope
that we can do south-south cooperation
well from our successes
but thank you my name is Hussein Dowd
and channel the past on poverty
alleviation fund say mother cash is good
for business and leadership and chairman
or anchor cooperation and our victory is
limited and also the dark foundation
it's by privilege to be able to address
you today and we've had an opportunity
to hear some of the viewpoints that been
expressed and I would like to add to say
we too would like the partnership in the
development of our subcontinent what
we're trying to do is try to develop the
education standards within Pakistan so
that based on that we are able to
address some of the critical issues
which our country faces which is
particularly the difficult we are having
today in acts of terrorism we've I
believe firmly that the solution to that
lies in education we need a long-term
solution and education if that long-term
solution and for that reason that we're
establishing the crisis proof of
business of leadership which hopefully
will produce the type of responsible
entrepreneurs who come back into society
and try to develop or develop and
contribute towards the realization of
that vision thank you so much for giving
me the option to say a few words